when we think about the moon landings
it's often seen through the lens of an
American victory in the space race
what isn't often discussed is how the
USSR america's rival reacted to the
landings was its government upset about
not being the first to the moon or were
they excited about such a major event in
human history the space race was a well
race to space between the USSR in the
USA during the 1960's well sort of it
was more about creating delivery
vehicles for nuclear weapons to destroy
each other but there was some sciencing
in the meantime the USSR was initially
in the lead having put an object in
orbit and then being the first to put a
man into space in the end though it was
the Americans who got there first with
Neil Armstrong being the first man to
walk on the moon incidentally the Soviet
Luna program was conducting an unmanned
mission at the time the astronauts were
on the moon which failed and crashed
into the surface so after this how did
the Soviets react did they try to
suppress it or claim that it didn't
happen nope first of all footage of the
landings was shown on Soviet television
but frankly not many Soviet citizens
owned a television and thus it wasn't
something many could watch it was
quickly reported afterwards in the
national media although it wasn't
front-page news but simply listed as a
run-of-the-mill story one thing the
Soviets didn't speak of was the failure
of the lunar lander they waited until
the timing was a bit less embarrassing
furthermore the Soviet government
congratulated the Americans on their
success and spoke of a future joint
mission to the moon this was mostly just
friendly overtures by the way both the
USSR and the USA were becoming
increasingly frustrated by the costs of
their space programs conveniently the
USSR also changed its mind on its own
moon program and it declared that such
landings were dangerous and
self-indulgent in terms of leadership
it's hard to know how any of them felt
on a personal level since you know
secretive communist state it's also
pretty easy to imagine that cosmonaut
Alexei Leonov would have been pretty
disappointed why because he had been
selected by Soviet leadership to be the
first man on the moon have the Soviets
got there first
another person of influence in the USSR
who was known to be furious was the
former first secretary Nikita Khrushchev
the Soviet space program was his doing
and for him not being the first to the
moon demonstrated that the Soviet Union
was losing its way so what about the
Soviet people in the broader communist
bloc many simply didn't hear much about
it or weren't too fast about America's
scientific endeavors there were some who
were upset with the USSR seeming to lose
to the Americans but barring that the
response to it was exceptionally muted
it was only really the scientists who
work for the USSR zone space program
that had any
sort of publicly positive response to it
and across the broader Warsaw Pact well
frankly the event didn't receive much
coverage there either the primary reason
being that many of its governments were
at the time commemorating 20 years of
communist rule
so in conclusion as many of you would
expect the Soviet response to the moon
landings was mixed and not very public
the leadership had wanted to get to the
moon first but had failed to do so and
given the timing of their own fair
admission they felt little need to make
too much fuss about it the USSR along
with its puppet states were focused on
the 20th anniversary of communism in
Eastern Europe which overshadowed the
American achievement for what it's worth
despite the USSR's lack of enthusiasm
they did congratulate the Americans and
frankly their response was a lot more
positive than the American wants a
Sputnik had been I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
extra thanks to my patreon supporters
which you can see on screen and with an
extra special thanks to James
Bissonnette David archaeologist Ozark a
flash Party Boyko Rob Waterhouse Chris
wicker Michael Reynolds Gustav Swan
David Silverman spinning three plates
Maggie packs Kowski Christian check'
Anthony Beckett Ike Skye Chappell and
Winston K wood
you